Stop what you're doing. Quick, recall your childhood phone number. Done? Okay, so did you say the numbers inside your head? Did the phone number appear as an image? Something else? You may be wondering why I'm asking you this seemingly off-the-wall question. Well, it's because I'm trying to get you to analyze your inner voice. You may have heard about the internet debate recently on inner monologues. It all started from a tweet that went viral. That tweet said that some people have an internal narrative, and some don't. What ensued were thousands of comments, retweets, and news stories on the topic. Turns out that people have a lot to say about their inner voices. Some people were shocked to learn that there are those who have a running commentary in their heads all the time, while others
停下手头的事。快，回想一下你童年的电话号码。想好了吗？好了，那你是在脑海里把数字念出来的吗？这个电话号码是以图像的形式出现的吗？还是其他形式？你可能在想，我为什么会问你这个看似古怪的问题。嗯，这是因为我在试图让你分析一下你的内心声音。你可能最近听说过关于内心独白的网络辩论。这一切都源于一条疯传的推文。那推文称，有些人有内心叙事，而有些人没有。随之而来的是关于这个话题的数千条评论、转发和新闻报道。事实证明，人们对自己的内心声音有很多话要说。有些人得知竟然有人在脑海里一直有一个进行中的画外音时感到震惊，而另一些人
don't have a permanent live-in narrator. According to our guest for this episode, University of Michigan psychology professor Dr. Ethan Cross, it's not exactly that simple. He says every healthy person has an inner voice, but how it manifests can vary dramatically from person to person. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a bi-weekly podcast from the American Psychological Association that explores the connections between psychological science and everyday life. I'm your host, Caitlin Luna. Dr. Cross is joining us via Skype from Ann Arbor, Michigan. Welcome, Dr. Cross. Thanks for having me.
则没有一个常驻的内心解说员。根据我们本期节目的嘉宾、密歇根大学心理学教授伊桑·克罗斯（Dr. Ethan Cross）博士所说，事情并没有那么简单。他说，每个健康的人都有内心声音，但它的表现形式因人而异。欢迎收听《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会（American Psychological Association）出品的一档双周播播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是主持人凯特琳·卢纳（Caitlin Luna）。克罗斯博士目前通过Skype从密歇根州安娜堡市与我们连线。欢迎您，克罗斯博士。谢谢邀请我来。
First, I want to establish one at inner monologue or inner voice is. How do you describe it? So I think of the inner voice as silent verbal processing. So the example you gave to begin the podcast was a really good one. So if I asked you to silently repeat a phone number in your head, that would be you activating your inner voice, so to speak, at a very basic level. So you're using verbal reasoning skills to play with information. And there are, of course, all sorts of ways that we can use internal silent language to help navigate our lives. So we can and often do use that verbal reasoning to keep information in mind, like when we rehearse a phone number or when we might silently rehearse what we're going to say in a given context.
首先，我想明确一下什么是内心独白或内心声音。你是如何描述它的？所以我认为内心声音就是无声的语言加工。所以你刚才在节目开始时举的例子就非常好。如果我让你在脑海里默默重复一个电话号码，这就好比你在某种程度上激活了你的内心声音，处于一个非常基础的水平。所以你正在使用语言推理技能来处理信息。当然，我们可以通过各种方式使用内部无声语言来帮助我们适应生活。我们可以而且经常使用这种语言推理来记住信息，比如当我们反复念诵一个电话号码时，或者当我们可能默默排练在特定情况下要说的话时。
So if I'm preparing for presentation, I might repeat something over and over, how I'm going to open the talk. But we also use language, silent language, the inner voice, so to speak, to do lots of other things, to imagine how we might respond. to different situations in our future. Some people report having conversations with themselves silently. Like you might see, you know, often popularizing movies, oh, my God, what am I going to do? If this happens, well, if this happens, I'll do that. And so the inner voice can take on lots of different roles, depending on the different context we find ourselves in.
所以，如果我正在为演讲做准备，我可能会一遍又一遍地重复某些内容，比如我将如何开始演讲。但我们也会使用语言，无声语言，也就是所谓的内心声音，来做许多其他事情，来想象我们可能会如何应对未来生活中的不同情况。有些人说他们会在脑海里自言自语。就像你可能看到的，你知道的，经常在流行电影里出现的那样，“天哪，我该怎么办？如果发生这种情况，嗯，如果发生这种情况，我就那样做。”因此，内心声音可以扮演许多不同的角色，这取决于我们所处的不同情境。
So how can those inner voices vary from person to person? As you said, every healthy person has an inner voice, but just how it appears is different. Yeah, so that's a great question. I think, you know, going back to the tweet, the different reactions that people had, what was so interesting to me about those with some people saying, oh, I never talk to myself. I don't have an inner voice. And other people saying, oh, I talk to myself all the time. I'm always engaged in some kind of inner monologue. I think part of the issue there is that people have different conceptions of what the inner voice actually is. So in my mind, the inner voice covers all. the terrain we just discussed, ranging from activities where you are silently rehearsing what you're trying to memorize or say. That's one manifestation of the inner voice. But another manifestation at the other end of the spectrum might be something like internal rumination where we're engaged, oh my God, what should I do? How is this going to happen? What if this happens? What if the carotavirus affects my family to use a current event? That's a different manifestation of the inner voice. And I do
那么，这些内心声音在不同人之间会有什么不同呢？正如你所说，每个健康的人都有内心声音，但它的呈现方式各有不同。是的，这是一个很好的问题。我想，你知道的，回到那条推文，人们有不同的反应，对我来说最有趣的是，有些人说：“噢，我从来不自言自语。我没有内心声音。”而另一些人则说：“噢，我一直在自言自语。我总是沉浸在某种内心独白中。”我认为其中的部分原因在于，人们对内心声音到底是什么有不同的理解。所以在我的脑海里，内心声音涵盖了我们刚刚讨论的所有领域，从你默默排练你试图记住或说出的话的活动。那是内心声音的一种表现形式。但光谱另一端的另一种表现形式可能是某种内部反刍，即我们沉浸在其中，“天哪，我该怎么办？这会怎么发生？如果发生这种情况怎么办？如果冠状病毒影响了我的家人怎么办——借用一个时事。”那是内心声音的另一种表现形式。而且我确实
think it is the case that some people engage in that kind of inner rumination a lot more than other people. Some people report not ruminating at all about things. And if you are equating the inner voice with a kind of ruminative thought process, then yeah, there's going to be huge variability in the degree to which people engage it. But if you go to the other end of the spectrum and look at the basic functions that the inner voice serves when it comes to memorizing information, keeping information active in your mind, then I think it is a universal that characterizes all quote unquote normal, healthy functioning individuals. So what are your thoughts about how this discussion just, you know, exploded on the internet?
认为，有些人的确比其他人更多地进行那种内心反刍。有些人说他们根本不会对事情进行反刍。如果你把内心声音等同于一种反刍的思维过程，那么是的，人们参与这种过程的程度会有巨大的差异。但如果你走到光谱的另一端，看看内心声音在记忆信息、让信息在脑海中保持活跃方面所起的基本功能，那么我认为这是一种普遍现象，它特征化了所有所谓的正常、健康的个体。那么，你对这场讨论如何在网上“爆发”有什么看法？
Are you surprised by that or, you know, what are your thoughts? I think it's fascinating. I think the inner voice is such an interesting topic because I think it is very salient to so many people. But it's an incredibly private experience. So many people spend a lot of time in their heads. By some estimates, we spend most of our waking hours thinking and verbally reflecting on our lives internally. And so it's something that many people are doing so frequently, but they're not necessarily talking about it with others. It's not as though I go meet some friends for coffee.
你对此感到惊讶吗，或者说，你有什么看法？我觉得这很迷人。我认为内心声音是一个非常有趣的话题，因为我觉得它对很多人来说都非常显而易见。但这是一种极其私密的体验。很多人花大量时间在自己的脑海里。据某些估计，我们清醒的大部分时间都在内部思考和对生活进行语言反思。所以这是许多人经常在做的事情，但他们不一定会与其他人谈论它。这并不是说我和一些朋友去喝咖啡时会说：
Hey, guess what I was just talking to myself about. And so it's this, it's very, very common, intimate experience we have, yet we don't talk about it very much. And when you look at the science, it's often coded with jargon, working memory, the phonological loop, which is the technical term that describes the component of working memory that is verbal, linguistic in nature. Right. Really complicated, jargon-filled scientific terms. And so I think once there was an opportunity to have a public conversation about this topic, many people were excited to participate. And they were particularly excited to participate when something somewhat counterintuitive was raised, the idea that some people don't have an internal monologue. Yeah, I think it just brings up that, you know, everyone wants to share their personal perspective and like, oh, I always think this way. I mean, for me, I have an internal narrator all the time. So I know what that camp feels like, but. Yeah, I had a conversation with someone recently who was asking me about some of this research.
“嘿，你猜我刚才在对自己说什么。”所以这是一个非常非常普遍、亲密的体验，然而我们却不怎么谈论它。当你审视科学时，它往往充满了专业术语，比如工作记忆、语音回路——这是描述工作记忆中本质上属于语言、语言学的成分的技术术语。没错。非常复杂的、充满术语的科学词汇。所以我想，一旦有机会就这个话题展开公开对话，许多人就很兴奋地参与进来。当提出某种有些反直觉的观点时，他们尤其兴奋，那就是有些人没有内心独白。是的，我认为这恰恰说明了，每个人都想分享他们的个人观点，比如“噢，我总是这样想”。对我和来说，我一直都有一个内心解说员。所以我知道那种阵营是什么感觉，但是。是的，我最近和一个人交谈，他向我询问了一些这方面的研究。
And this person was saying, I work at home alone. This was a web designer. And he was saying, all I do is talk to myself all the time in my head. That's just my life. And so the notion that that reality might not characterize other people's experiences was to use the technical term, a mindblower for that person. And so I think that's what we saw happen on Twitter surrounding this conversation. So, you know, how is this different from people who hear voices?
这个人说：“我一个人在家工作。”这是一个网页设计师。他说：“我所做的一切就是在脑海里一直对自己说话。这就是我的生活。”所以，这种现实可能并不符合其他人的体验的观点，用专业术语来说，对那个人来说是一个“大开眼界”的时刻。所以我想这就是我们在推特上看到围绕这场对话发生的事情。那么，这与听到声音的人有什么不同呢？
I mean, hearing voices is often associated with serious mental illness like schizophrenia. So can you differentiate between what we mean by internal monologue and, hearing voices? Yeah, it's a great question. And there are a couple of distinctions worth noting. So oftentimes, when we're talking about the inner voice, I'm talking about the awareness that verbal processing is occurring, but that I can, so, you know, when I repeat a phone number, my child's phone number, I can, I have the subjective experience of using language to repeat that number. I'm not just seeing it. I'm internally hearing those words. But I know that the source of that, quote, unquote, inner voice is me, right?
我的意思是，听到声音通常与精神分裂症等严重的精神疾病有关。所以你能区分我们所说的内心独白和听到声音吗？是的，这是一个很好的问题。有几个区别值得注意。所以通常情况下，当我们谈论内心声音时，我指的是一种意识到语言加工正在发生的觉察，但我可以，所以，你知道，当我重复一个电话号码，我孩子的电话号码时，我能够，我有使用语言重复那个数字的主观体验。我不只是看到它。我在内部听到那些话。但我知道那个所谓的“内心声音”的源头是我自己，对吧？
I don't think that the voice is coming from some other external entity like the government or aliens and so forth. So that's the first distinction worth noting that typically when we're talking about the inner voice, we usually, we know where it's coming from and it's usually ourselves and has this abstract quality to it. Now, that's not to say that we're not capable of hearing other voices, too. So many people, if I asked you to imagine your mother telling you to clean up your room right now, you could probably simulate that experience and actually hear your mother's voice in your head or some approximation of it. And so that would be you hearing your mom. And so we can hear other voices. But again, typically you know that the voice is coming from, you are the source of your mom's voice. It's not your mom implanting herself in your head and controlling you.
我不认为这个声音来自其他外部实体，比如政府或外星人等等。所以这是值得注意的第一个区别，通常当我们谈论内心声音时，我们通常，我们知道它来自哪里，而且通常是我们自己，并且具有这种抽象的品质。现在，这并不是说我们没有能力听到其他声音。所以很多人，如果我让你想象你的母亲现在叫你收拾房间，你可能能够模拟那种体验，并在脑海中实际听到你母亲的声音或某种近似的声音。所以那将是你听到你妈妈的声音。所以我们可以听到其他声音。但同样，通常你知道声音来自哪里，你是你妈妈声音的源头。不是你妈妈把自己植入你的脑海并控制你。
And so when we get into mental illness, this line between knowing the source of the voice, whether it's coming from me or the external world, that tends to get blurred. And so oftentimes in the case of schizophrenia and other kinds of auditory hallucinations, we are a true. distributing this voice to another agent. Now, I should say there have been studies which ask people, like, do you ever hear voices and believe they come from other sources? For example, like God is the voice in your head delivering a message from God? And there are people who do not need, like, diagnostic criteria for mental illness who do report hearing the voice of God and believing it's coming from somewhere else. So the line between mental illness and normality in this context, it's not cut and dry. There are other elements that go into a diagnosis.
所以当我们谈到精神疾病时，知道声音源头（无论是来自我自己还是外部世界）的这条界限，往往会变得模糊。因此，在精神分裂症和其他类型的幻听的情况下，我们往往真正地将这个声音归因于另一个主体。现在，我应该说，曾有一些研究询问人们，比如：你是否曾听到过声音并相信它们来自其他来源？例如，上帝是你脑海里传递上帝信息的那个声音？有些人并不符合精神疾病的诊断标准，但他们确实报告说听到了上帝的声音并相信它来自其他地方。因此，在这种背景下，精神疾病与正常之间的界限并不是非黑即白的。诊断中还有其他因素。
Does that help give you a sense of the terrain? Yeah, it does. And I think I've often heard it's people who have auditory hallucinations. It's like as a person was next to you talking to you as opposed to inside your head. Is that correct or is it very? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
这是否有助于让你对这个领域有个概念？是的，确实如此。我想我经常听说，有幻听的人感觉就像有人在你旁边对你说话，而不是在你的脑海里。这是正确的还是非常……？是的。是的。是的。
I mean, that captures part of the phenomenon. And many perfectly normal healthy individuals experience those kinds of auditory hallucinations at some point in their life. And so when we're making diagnoses of mental illness, we're taking into account lots of information, not just the frequency of those kinds of events, but other diagnostic criteria too. Okay. So people can rest easy if they have an inner monologue. They're not likely suffering from a serious mental illness. Yeah. If that's the only thing that's an inner monologue.
我的意思是，这捕捉到了这种现象的一部分。许多完全正常健康的个体在他们生命中的某个时刻也会经历那种类型的幻听。因此，当我们诊断精神疾病时，我们会考虑大量信息，不仅考虑这些事件的频率，还考虑其他诊断标准。好吧。所以如果人们有内心独白，他们大可放心。他们不太可能患有严重的精神疾病。是的，如果内心独白只是那种情况的话。
Intermonologue. I think we'd all be in big trouble if that were the case. Yeah, exactly. So are we born with an inner monologue and when does it develop? That's a great question. And, you know, there's not a ton of research that looks at this. What we do know is that what I've seen, the earliest study I've seen, looking at verbal working memory, which is when we are using language to rehearse information
内心独白。如果真是那样的话，我们可就都有大麻烦了。是的，完全正确。那么我们天生就有内心独白吗？它是什么时候发育的？这是一个很好的问题。而且，你知道的，并没有大量研究探讨这一点。我们所知道的是，我看到的关于言语工作记忆（也就是我们使用语言来排练信息）最早的研究，
and keeping it fresh in mind, that that capacity we can see evidence for it, at around 18 months of age. But that's not to say that it doesn't develop earlier. That's simply what we've documented thus far. And so relatively early on in the lifespan, although that, you know, of course, depends on who you're talking to. But that's the earliest I've seen evidence for this coming online. And does it help children develop self-control?
并使其在脑海中保持新鲜，我们可以在大约18个月大的时候看到这种能力的证据。但这并不是说它没有更早发育。这只是我们迄今为止记录到的情况。因此，在生命周期的相对早期，虽然这当然取决于你在和谁谈论。但这是我看到这种能力上线的最早证据。它能帮助儿童发展自我控制能力吗？
I think you, you know, I spoke briefly about that, how a child might be told instructions by a parent, and then they repeat them out loud, and it becomes their inner voice. maybe to help them regulate their behavior, put away your toys, wash your hands, that kind of thing. Yeah, so this is a really interesting angle on all this work. So many psychologists believe that the inner voice is actually central to how we learn to control ourselves. And so one of the key ways that we learn self-control is through the interactions we have with our parents,
我想你，你知道的，我刚才简短地谈到了这一点，家长可能会对孩子下达指令，然后孩子会大声重复，它就变成了他们的内心声音。也许是为了帮助他们调节行为，收拾玩具，洗手之类的事情。是的，所以这是这项工作的一个非常有趣的切入点。许多心理学家认为，内心声音实际上是我们学习如何控制自己的核心。因此，我们学习自我控制的关键途径之一，是通过我们与父母的互动，
where our parents or caretakers give us instructions. They tell us what to do and what not to do. So put your toys away and don't pick your nose at the dinner table. Well, you probably shouldn't pick your nose anywhere, but you get the point. And if you've ever spent some time around children, what you often see is this really fun and curious and magical kind of event where kids go off on their own and they start talking to themselves oftentimes out loud to begin with. They're like giving themselves instructions, right?
父母或看护者给我们下达指令。他们告诉我们该做什么，不该做什么。所以，把你的玩具收好，不要在餐桌上挖鼻孔。好吧，你可能在任何地方都不应该挖鼻孔，但你懂我的意思。如果你曾在孩子身边呆过一段时间，你经常会看到这种非常有趣、好奇和神奇的现象：孩子们自己走开，开始自言自语，通常一开始是很大声地自言自语。他们就像是在给自己下达指令，对吧？
So like, no, I shouldn't pick my nose at the dinner table or, or yes, I have to go clean my room. And they're essentially repeating what their caretakers are saying, are telling them to do, right? They're repeating it to themselves. And the idea is that this is the way in which self-control is developing. Messages from our caretakers and our culture more generally are getting injected into our own lives. And we're rehearsing them as kids out loud. And what happens is that over time, we don't do that out loud, but that process then goes internal. It becomes a silent inner monologue where we are directing ourselves, so to speak, you know, privately.
所以就像，不，我不应该在餐桌上挖鼻孔，或者，是的，我必须去打扫我的房间。他们本质上是在重复他们的看护者所说的话，告诉他们该做什么，对吧？他们对自己重复这些话。这个想法是，这就是自我控制能力发展的方式。来自我们看护者和更广泛文化的讯息正被注入到我们自己的生活中。而我们在小时候会大声地排练它们。发生的情况是，随着时间的推移，我们不再大声说出来了，但这个过程随后转入了内部。它变成了一个无声的内心独白，我们在其中指挥自己，可以说是在私下里进行。
And that then becomes a tool that some psychologists and scientists, myself included, think that we rely on throughout our lives as a very powerful tool, this ability to use language to control ourselves. One thing when I read an interview you did with Today.com, and you spoke about how you don't necessarily need to hear to have an inner voice. You know, I find that interesting because I, in a previous life, I worked at Gallaudet University, which is a deaf university. So I was surrounded by deaf people on campus all the time and have deaf friends and no sign language and all that. So what you said is that you don't need to have, you know, you don't need to be able to hear to have an inner voice that perhaps maybe a deaf person, you know, sees sign language in their head, sees words, that sort of thing. So can you elaborate on that? Yeah. So there's like a really interesting question, right? If this inner voice is central to, is fundamental to how we live our lives, right? It's used in all these different capacities.
这随后成了一种工具，一些心理学家和科学家（包括我自己）认为，我们一生都在依赖它作为一种非常强大的工具，这种使用语言来控制自己的能力。有一件事，当我读到你为Today.com做的一篇采访时，你谈到了你并不一定需要有听力才能拥有内心声音。你知道，我觉得这很有趣，因为我，在过去的生活中，曾在加劳德特大学（Gallaudet University）工作过，那是一所聋人大学。所以我一直被校园里的聋人群体包围，有聋人朋友，懂手语等等。所以你所说的是，你不需要，你知道的，不需要有听力才能拥有内心声音，或许聋人在脑海里看到手语、看到文字，诸如此类。所以你能详细说明一下吗？是的。所以这是一个非常有趣的问题，对吧？如果这个内心声音是核心，是我们如何生活的基石，对吧？它被用于所有这些不同的能力中。
What happens to people who have impoverished verbal capacities or linguistic capacities? And so hearing impaired populations are one. And so there has been a little bit of work on this that shows, as you just implied, that people who are hearing impaired also report silently talking to themselves, so to speak. And one of the ways in which they report doing so is simply using the same communication channel that they use to communicate with people in their worlds, right? So they're engaging in not in inner talking, so verbally, but with inner signing, using seeing signs in their mind as they are engaging in this kind of internal introspection. So it's happening, but they're using a different modality to do it.
那些语言能力受损或语言能力贫乏的人会怎么样？听力受损的人群就是其中之一。所以有一些关于这方面的研究表明，正如你刚才暗示的那样，听力受损的人也报告说他们会默默地对自己说话，可以说是这样。他们报告这样做的方式之一，仅仅是使用他们用来与世界各地的人进行交流的相同的沟通渠道，对吧？所以他们从事的不是内心的说话，即口头上的，而是内心的手语，在进行这种内部内省时，在脑海中看到手语。所以这正在发生，但他们使用的是不同的模态来做到这一点。
Have you done any research on bilingual people? Would a bilingual person have an inner monologue in two languages? You know, I haven't done any work on that. It's really interesting. There is work showing that among bilinguals, the language that you use to reach, reason about experiences can have in some cases quite interesting implications for how you think. So if you think about an emotional event in your second language, the impact it has on you is blunted, right?
你做过关于双语者的研究吗？双语者会用两种语言进行内心独白吗？你知道，我没有做过这方面的研究。这真的很有趣。有研究表明，在双语者中，你用来推理经历的语言在某些情况下会对你的思考方式产生相当有趣的影响。如果你用第二语言去思考一个情绪事件，它对你的影响就会减弱，对吧？
So it doesn't have the same emotional punch than if you think about it in your native language. Your native language is the language where you learn swear words and, you know, your first learning like your experience of emotion is encoded using your native language. And so the idea is that when you switch to the non-native language, those emotional tags and experiences are stripped away as well. So there's a lot of work in that area. It's also, I think, I speak different languages and it's easy for me to swap into another language deliberately if I want to silently speak Spanish and rehearse a number, I can. So I think that flexibility exists. The question of when, you know, do people oscillate back and forth? That I'm not sure. I am aware of some
所以它没有你用母语思考时那么强烈的精神冲击。你的母语是你学习脏话的语言，你知道的，你对情绪的最初学习和体验是通过你的母语编码的。所以这个想法是，当你切换到非母语时，那些情绪标签和体验也被剥离了。所以该领域有很多研究。这也是，我认为，我说的不同的语言，如果我愿意，我可以很容易地刻意切换到另一种语言，默默地说西班牙语并排练一个数字。所以我认为这种灵活性是存在的。人们是否会前后摇摆不定的问题？这一点我不确定。我了解一些
anecdotal reports among people who have studied abroad who tell me that they've begun, they start dreaming in a foreign language. And we do find our inner voice perking up during our dreams too. Our dreams often have verbal information. You process verbally in our dreams. too. So I think there's some, I think it is likely to occur, but I just don't know of any evidence that has really nailed it. Yeah, an interesting area that could be studied in the future, for sure. Have you done any research about people who talk out loud to themselves? You know, we have, so it's a great question. It often comes up. We haven't touched this yet, and I think it's a really interesting topic. So in some work, we find that, you know, if you
留学生当中的轶事报告，他们告诉我，他们开始用外语做梦了。而且我们确实发现我们的内心声音在做梦期间也会活跃起来。我们的梦里经常有语言信息。我们在梦中也会进行语言加工。所以我认为有一些，我认为这很可能会发生，但我只是不知道有什么证据真正证实了这一点。是的，这确实是一个未来可以研究的有趣领域。你做过关于大声对自己说话的人的研究吗？你知道，我们做过，所以这是一个很好的问题。这经常出现。我们还没接触过这个，我认为这是一个非常有趣的话题。所以在一些研究中，我们发现，你知道，如果你
talk to yourself, in particular in the third person, when you're trying to manage yourself. So if I've got a really, you know, a big presentation and I'm nervous, try to work through my feelings, not in the first one, hey, what am I going to say? But what is Ethan going to say? Why is Ethan nervous? Engaging in that shift from first to third can be helpful for giving people distance from their experience, making, hey, it's not about you, like it's about someone else, and relieving anxiety and improving performance as a result. And so some people often ask, well, what if you did that out loud? And my intuition is that it would be likewise beneficial, but, and this is an important but, you can't do it when other people are around you because there's a huge social stigma that exists about people talking
对自己说话，特别是在试图管理自己时使用第三人称。所以如果我真的有一个，你知道，很重要的演讲，我很紧张，试图理清我的情绪，不是用第一人称，“嘿，我要说什么？”而是“伊桑要说什么？伊桑为什么紧张？”从第一人称转变到第三人称，有助于让人与自己的体验保持距离，认识到“嘿，这与你无关，这是关于别人的”，从而减轻焦虑，进而提高表现。所以有些人经常会问，如果你大声说出来会怎么样？我的直觉是，这同样会有益，但是，这是一个重要的“但是”，当其他人围在你身边时，你不能这样做，因为存在巨大的社会污 stigma（污名），关于人们大声对自己说话会强烈地违反社会规范。所以我认为这可能会对人们产生其他影响。所以对你问题的简短回答——我刚刚没有直接回答你——那就是没有，我们还没有大声研究过这一点。但我猜想，在某些情况下——我们知道在某些情况下，人们会感到沮丧，几乎到了无法控制沮丧的程度，他们会脱口而出对自己说的话。围绕这种行为有一整套有趣的问题，值得未来进行研究。那么，你的内心独白何时会从
to themselves out loud that violate social convention quite powerfully. And so I think there are other ramifications that that might have for people. So the short answer to your question, which I just didn't give you, is that no, we haven't looked at this out loud. But I think my guess is that there are instances, like we know there are instances where people are frustrated and almost to the point of not being able to contain their frustration, they blurk things out to themselves. And there's a whole set of interesting questions that surround that behavior that warrant future study. So when does your inner model log go from? being helpful to being self-defeating?
有帮助转变为适得其反？
So I think that happens when we, you know, we often use our inner monologue to solve problems. And it can be a really tool, a useful tool for helping us think through, like simulate different possibilities for what might happen and come to a realization about how we should respond or behave or act.
所以我想，这种情况发生在我们，你知道的，我们经常使用内心独白来解决问题。它确实可以是一个很有用的工具，帮助我们思考，比如模拟可能发生的不同可能性，并对我们应该如何反应、表现或行动得出认识。
And so super duper useful ability, right? The ability to simulate and plan and the inner voice is something that helps us do that in many contexts. Where I think the inner voice can and does get us into not just trouble, but big trouble, is when that planning simulation process runs off course as it does when we tend to ruminate or worry excessively or perseverate on negative things in our lives. There's a ton of data showing that when we are constantly rehearsing the negative things. Well, what if this happens, and what should I do or I can't believe I said this and how am I going to feel?
所以这是一种超级无敌有用的能力，对吧？模拟和规划的能力，并且内心声音在许多情境下都能帮助我们做到这一点。我认为内心声音不仅会给我们带来麻烦，而且会给我们带来大麻烦的地方在于，当那种规划模拟过程偏离轨道时，正如我们在倾向于反刍、过度担忧或对生活中的消极事情念念不忘时所做的那样。有大量数据表明，当我们不断排练消极的事情时。“好吧，如果发生这种情况该怎么办，我该怎么做，或者我简直不敢相信我说过这个，我会有什么感觉？”
And what if this happens, engaging that kind of cyclical verbal negative dynamic? What that does is that it elevates our stress levels and it keeps those stress levels elevated over time. And that can have strikingly negative implications for many of the things that matter most to us, for example, are helped, right? So there's a lot of data showing that when we're ruminating and persevering, and perseverating excessively over negative things in our life that activates our fight or flight response and keeps it activated chronically over time. Not very good. If we're spending all
“如果发生这种情况怎么办，”陷入那种循环的、言语的、消极的动态中。这样做会升高我们的压力水平，并随着时间的推移使这些压力水平保持在高位。这可能对对我们最重要许多事情产生惊人的消极影响，例如，我们的健康，对吧？所以有很多数据表明，当我们过度反刍和执着于生活中的消极事情时，这会激活我们的战斗或逃跑反应，并在随着时间的推移使其长期保持激活状态。这可不太好。如果我们把所有的
of our time, you know, lost in verbal thought, so to speak, over the negative things in our lives, our ability to think and reason is limited. So what happens if you're spending all your time occupying the limited resources you have for thinking abstractly and planning, focusing on this one negative thing or several negative things, that then basically tunes out other important areas of your life where you might want to use your mind, your problem-solving capacity. And so it can affect our decision-making. Like, imagine, for example, have you ever had the experience of trying to read a book when you're ruminating about a problem? Like when that happens, many people report anecdotally not being able to focus because these other negative thoughts are intruding in.
时间，你知道的，都迷失在言语思考中，可以说是在生活中的消极事情上，我们思考和推理的能力就会受到限制。所以，如果你把所有的资源都花在占用你用于抽象思维和规划的有限资源上，专注于这一个消极事情或几个消极事情上，那么这基本上就会屏蔽掉你生活中其他可能想要运用大脑和解决问题能力的的重要领域。因此它会影响我们的决策。想象一下，例如，你有没有过这种经历：当你正在为一个问题反刍时，试图去读一本书？当这种情况发生时，许多人通过轶事报告说自己无法集中注意力，因为这些其他消极想法正在侵入进来。
So it can really distract us from being good listeners or doing the jobs that we have at work or at school. And then finally, it can interfere with our relationships because one of the things we know about people when they experience heightened levels of inner voice run amok, so to speak, they tend to want to verbalize and talk about it to other people to get social support, and that's a great instinct. But what often happens is because these experiences are chronic, right? The inner voice is running on overdrive. The inner critic maybe is taking over.
所以这确实会分散我们的注意力，让我们无法成为好的倾听者，或者无法做好我们在工作或学校里的工作。最后，它会干扰我们的关系，因为我们对经历高度内心独白失控（可以说）的人了解的一点是，他们往往倾向于将其实际说出来并与其他人谈论，以获得社会支持，这是一个极好的直觉。但经常发生的情况是，由于这些体验是慢性的，对吧？内心声音在超速运转。内部批评者可能正在接管。
Then they keep talking about it over and over and over again. And that can actually push those we love away. And so it can be not very good for us when the inner voice runs awry. So you're a director of your university's emotion and self-control lab. And in your lab, you've done research on rumination. And you've said that self-distance can help. Can you explain what self-distancing is and how you can do this when something upsetting happens? Sure.
然后他们就一直不断地谈论这件事。这实际上会把我们所爱的人推开。因此，当内心独白失控时，对我们来说可能并不是一件好事。所以你是你大学的情绪与自我控制实验室的主任。在你的实验室里，你做过关于反刍的研究。你说过自我疏离会有能帮助。你能解释一下什么是自我疏离，以及当发生令人沮丧的事情时如何做到这一点吗？当然。
And so self-distance is the ability to essentially focus on yourself from a more objective, psychologically removed perspective. To illustrate why it matters, I usually ask people to think of a time when a friend or loved one came to them with a problem that they were ruminating about or worried excessively about. And the problem wasn't really relative to them, just their friend. In these situations, most people report being able to easily coach their friends through their problems, give them advice about what they should do, how they should act, and so forth. And I would argue, and there's lots of days to support this, that the reason for that is because the problem is not happening
所以自我疏离本质上是从一个更客观、心理上有距离的视角来关注自己的能力。为了说明为什么它很重要，我通常会让大家回想这样一个时刻：一个朋友或亲人带着他们一直在反刍或过度担忧的问题来找他们。而这个问题实际上与他们自己无关，只是他们的朋友的事。在这种情况下，大多数人都报告说能够轻松地指导朋友度过难关，给他们关于应该做什么、如何行事等方面的建议。我认为，而且有大量数据支持这一点，原因在于这个问题并没有发生
to you, right? So you have psychological distance from that experience. And as a result, you're capable of thinking about it more objectively. What we've learned about human beings is that we have evolved to possess different psychological hacks, if you will, for providing us with distance from our own problems. And that's what we've studied in the lab. What are these different tools that people possess to get some mental space from the problems that they're experiencing so that they can think about them more similar to how they might think about another person's problems?
在你身上，对吧？所以你对那种经历有心理距离。因此，你能够更客观地思考它。我们对人类的了解是，我们进化出了不同的心理小技巧，如果你愿意的话，可以为我们提供与自身问题保持距离的手段。这就是我们在实验室里研究的内容。人们拥有哪些不同的工具来从他们正在经历的问题中获得一些心理空间，以便他们能够更类似于思考另一个人的问题那样去思考这些问题？
And one important tool that we've studied along those lines is language, is the inner voice. So in a certain sense, there are ways of using the inner voice to combat the toxic inner voice when it runs away. And one of those tools is something we call distanced self-talk, which involves using your own name or other non-first-person pronouns, words like you or he or she, to think about your life when you're experiencing probably. problematic rumination or anxiety provoking experiences. So if I'm really worried about making a good impression on you during this podcast, instead of thinking, what am I going to say and why am I going to say that? I might think, well, what is Ethan going to say and why is Ethan going to say that? And what we find is that that subtle shift from I to using your own name promotes distance
我们沿着这些思路研究的一个重要工具就是语言，也就是内心声音。所以在某种程度上，有办法利用内心声音来对抗失控的有毒内心声音。其中一个工具就是我们所说的“疏离性自我对话”，它包括在经历可能有问题的反刍或引发焦虑的体验时，使用你自己的名字或其他非第一人称代词（如“你”、“他”或“她”）来思考你的生活。所以如果我真的很担心在这个播客中给你留下好印象，我不会去想“我要说什么，我为什么要这么说？”，而是可能会想“伊桑要说什么，伊桑为什么要这么说？”我们发现，从“我”到使用你自己的名字的这种微妙转变促进了距离感，
and helps people think about experiences in a more healthy and ultimately adaptive way. And I'll just add one more point. The reason we think that this is so effective is because if you think about the context in which we use names, right? Most of the time we use names when we think about or refer to other people, right? Like 99% of the time we use names or are thinking about or referring to another person. And so the idea is that when you use a name to refer to yourself, it's almost like this little psychological jujitsu move where you're getting yourself to think about yourself like you are someone else.
并帮助人们以更健康、最终更具适应性的方式思考体验。我再补充一点。我们认为这之所以如此有效，是因为如果你想想我们使用名字的语境，对吧？我们绝大多数时间都是在思考或指代其他人时才使用名字，对吧？就像99%的时间我们都在使用名字或思考或指代另一个人。所以这个想法是，当你用一个名字来指代你自己时，这几乎就像是一个微小的心理柔术动作，你是在让自己像对待别人一样来思考自己。
So you're using language to change the way you're actually thinking about the self. So that's distant self-talk in a nutshell. That's great. I've never even thought about that as a way to think of yourself and the third person as you're going through a challenging time because you can also, again, treat. yourself as though you would treat a friend because you likely would treat a friend or family member, you know, loved one better than you might talk to yourself in a lot of cases. So are there other distancing strategies you can employ when needed? Yeah. So there's a whole toolbox of distancing
所以你是在用语言改变你实际思考自我的方式。简而言之，这就是疏离性自我对话。这太棒了。我甚至从未想过在经历艰难时期时，这可以作为一种在第三人称中思考自己并对待自己的方式，因为你也可以像对待朋友那样对待自己，因为在很多情况下，你对待朋友或家庭成员（你知道的，所爱的人）可能会比你对自己说话时要好。那么，在需要时，你还能采用其他疏离策略吗？是的。所以存在着一整套疏离策略工具箱。
strategies that exist. Another another one that is empirically validated and I find personally find useful is to imagine how you're going to feel a week or a month or a year later, right? So something called temporal distancing. It's kind of like a mental time travel where oftentimes we get so consumed with what is happening in the moment. We forget that with time, things change and actually oftentimes things get better. And so if you find yourself ruminating about something, you might think, well, how am I going to feel about this a year from now or 10 years from now? That's another kind of distancing hack. There's some work showing that writing expressively about your experiences.
另一个经过实证验证的、我个人觉得很有用的策略是：想象一下你在一周、一个月或一年后的感受，对吧？这叫做时间疏离。这有点像心理时间旅行，通常我们太过于沉迷于当下发生的事情。我们忘记了随着时间推移，事情会发生变化，而且实际上很多时候事情会变得更好。所以如果你发现自己在为某事反刍，你可能会想，“一年后或十年后我对这件事会有什么感觉？”这是另一种疏离小技巧。有一些研究表明，以表达性的方式写下你的经历。
So doing something like journaling is also something that has been shown to be effective for helping people cope with negative experiences. And one pathway through which it works, not the only one, but one has to do with distance, right? So when you're writing about your own experiences,
因此，做诸如写日记之类的事情也被证明对帮助人们应对消极体验是有效的。它起作用的途径之一（并非唯一途径）与距离感有关，对吧？所以当你写下自己的经历时，
you're becoming the target, right? Like you're thinking about yourself as this character in a play that is your life. And so there's a distancing quality, quality that writing about one's experiences can also have. And so those are just a couple of examples. There are quite a few more that exist that you can read about in various places. I'm happy to refer people to sources if that'd be helpful. We can touch on that a bit at the end. So you also research social rejection and emotional pain. Why and how does something emotional cause physical
你成了目标，对吧？就像你在把自己当作你生活的戏剧中的一个角色来思考。因此，写下自己的经历也可以具有疏离的品质。这些只是几个例子。还有相当多的其他例子，你可以在各种地方读到。如果对大家有帮助，我很乐意向大家推荐资源。我们可以在最后稍微谈谈这一点。所以你还研究社会拒绝和情感痛苦。为什么以及情感如何引起身体
pain. Great question. And yeah, we have done some work looking at, you know, there's this curious phenomenon where people who find themselves ostracized or excommunicated or just rejected from work or in love do this seemingly strange thing. They use this language of physical pain to talk about their experience. They say, my feelings are hurt. I'm in pain. And so that has been curious, a curious kind of phenomenon for many of us in the field. Why would a person use words that are normally specific to the experience of physical pain to describe this emotional experience? And one idea has to do with the fact that because our social relationships are so
疼痛？这是一个很好的问题。是的，我们做了一些研究，发现有一个奇怪的现象：那些发现自己被驱逐、被开除，或者在工作或爱情中被拒绝的人，会做一件看似奇怪的事情。他们用身体痛苦的语言来谈论他们的体验。他们说：“我的心受伤了。我很痛苦。”因此，这对于我们领域的许多人来说一直是一个奇怪的现象。为什么一个人会使用通常专门用于身体痛苦体验的词语来描述这种情感体验？其中一个想法与这样一个事实有关：因为我们的社会关系是
absolutely central to our ability to succeed and thrive in this world, right? Human beings, we are a social species. We thrive on these social relationships. that we have evolved in ways that we need really powerful cues that alert us to danger when those social ties are severed. And one of the best systems that exist for warning us of potential danger is pain, right? If we go to touch a stove and we sense heat, we instantly pull back our hand. And so the idea is that within human beings, we make use of the physical pain system that exists. It's a very primitive system for alerting us to danger and getting us to quickly
我们在这个世界上取得成功和繁荣的能力的核心，对吧？人类，我们是一个社会物种。我们在这些社会关系中蓬勃发展。我们已经进化出这样一种方式：当这些社会纽带被切断时，我们需要真正强大的线索来警告我们注意危险。而警告我们潜在危险的最好的系统之一就是痛苦，对吧？如果我们去触摸一个炉子并感到热，我们会立即把手缩回来。因此，这个想法是，在人类内部，我们利用了现有的身体痛苦系统。这是一个非常原始的系统，用于向我们发出危险警报并促使我们迅速
respond as a result. And so we rely on that system when we experience potentially socially threatening experiences. Does that make sense? Yeah, it does. It does. And how can people better cope with rejection? Well, you know, many of the tools that exist for coping with negative experiences more generally, like experiences that might cause you. If you feel anxiety or anger or sadness also apply to coping with rejection. So some of the distancing tools that we've already talked about, I think would be useful for coping with rejection. There's some data to support that. They're also, of course, leveraging our social relationships with other people. So finding people to talk about our problems who are skilled in helping us see the bigger picture, not getting
做出反应。因此，当我们经历潜在的社会威胁性体验时，我们会依赖该系统。这说得通吗？是的，说得通。确实如此。那么人们如何能更好地应对拒绝呢？嗯，你知道的，许多用于更普遍地应对消极体验的工具，比如可能引起你焦虑、愤怒或悲伤的体验，同样适用于应对拒绝。因此，我们已经讨论过的一些疏离工具，我认为对于应对拒绝也会很有用。有一些数据支持这一点。当然，还有利用我们与其他人的社会关系。所以寻找那些擅长帮助我们看到大局、而不局限于细节的人来谈论我们的问题。所以很多时候你去找别人寻求帮助，而他们实际上并没有帮到你，因为在他们试图表现得支持你的过程中，他们最终只是让你去思考你因此感觉有多糟糕。
stuck in the detail. So oftentimes you go to other people for help, and they don't actually help you because in their attempts to be supportive, they end up just getting you to think through how awful you feel as a result. So to make it concrete, let's say you're rejected. Oh, my God, I can't believe you were just rejected. You must feel awful. I'm so sorry. Where did it happen? What happened?
为了使其具体化，假设你被拒绝了。“天哪，我简直不敢相信你刚刚被拒绝了。你一定感觉糟透了。我很抱歉。它在哪里发生 的？发生了什么？”
So in my attempt to connect with you, I am essentially just getting you to think over and over about to rehearse the negative features of your experience. And that can be not so helpful long term. So there's some evidence that what makes really good social support is when you go to someone else, they're capable of connecting with you and showing you that they care. So they learn a little bit about what you're going through. But then they really shift to trying to help you put the experience in perspective. Right. So, well, you know what?
所以在我试图与你建立联系的过程中，我本质上只是让你一遍又一遍地去思考、去排练你经历中的消极特征。从长远来看，这可能并没有那么有帮助。因此有一些证据表明，真正好的社会支持是，当你去找别人时，他们能够与你建立联系并向你表明他们在乎。所以他们对你正在经历的事情有了一些了解。但随后他们真正转向试图帮助你把这种体验置于正确的视角之中。对吧，所以，嗯，你知道吗？
They're more efficiency. Right. Like that's the cliche, right? or let's look at the big picture. You know what? Two years from now, things are going to look different. So in a certain sense, other people can be tools that help give us more space, more perspective, more distance.
它们更有效率。对的。就像老生常谈一样，对吧？或者我们来看看宏观局势。你知道吗？两年后，情况会有所不同。因此，从某种意义上说，其他人可以成为工具，帮助我们获得更多的空间、更多的视角、更多的距离。
And so that's another thing that people can do. And there are boatloads of other techniques and tools that exist for helping people manage rumination that, you know, nature is one that has been recently quite extensively studied. there are religious rituals that people engage in, or even non-religious rituals that can be helpful. So that's really a huge question with lots of, we probably need a lot more time to get into all those techniques in depth. But you've offered a lot of great tips in terms of how to handle rumination, rejection, those things that just happen. I think most people can say that those things have happened in their lives at some point. I want to turn out to some other work you do in your lab, and you've done some research on social networking sites and well-being.
这也是人们可以做到的另一件事。还有大量其他技术和工具可用于帮助人们应对反刍思维，比如自然就是最近被广泛研究的一个方面。人们会参与宗教仪式，甚至是非宗教仪式也会有所帮助。所以这确实是一个巨大的问题，有很多，我们可能需要更多时间来深入探讨所有这些技术。但你已经提出了许多绝妙的建议，关于如何处理反刍思维、拒绝以及那些偶然发生的事情。我想大多数人都可以说这些事情在他们生活中的某个时刻发生过。我想转而谈谈你在实验室里所做的其他一些工作，你对社交网站和幸福感做了一些研究。
And in a paper you published, you ask that very question that's on the minds of many today, does social media make us feel better or worse? What did you find? So what we find is that so when you use social media in a particular way, it predicts a decline in how good people feel. And in particular, when people passively use social media, meaning that they log into their social media. sites. We've studied primarily Facebook and they browse what's happening in their social media universe. That tends to lead people to feel envy, feelings of envy, which in turn predicts declines and how good they feel. And how we think all this works is as follows. We know that people are motivated to present themselves flatteringly in the eyes of others. We all do it all
在你发表的一篇论文中，你提出了当今许多人都在思考的那个问题：社交媒体究竟让我们感觉更好还是更糟？你发现了什么？所以我们发现，当你以特定方式使用社交媒体时，它预示着人们感觉良好的程度会下降。特别是，当人们被动使用社交媒体时，这意味着他们登录了他们的社交媒体。我们主要研究了Facebook，他们浏览社交媒体世界中发生的事情。这往往会让人产生嫉妒，产生嫉妒感，而这反过来又预示着他们感觉良好的程度会下降。我们认为这一切的运作方式如下。我们知道人们有动力在他人眼中表现得讨人喜欢。我们所有人都在这样做
the time, not just on social media, but in the offline world as well. So I wake up. I usually, if I know I'm going to see other people, I shave, I comb my hair, I put on a shirt that's not ripped and stained. And I do that because I want to convey a particular impression. But there are limits to how that impression management process works in the offline world, right? Like I can comb my hair and shave, but, you know, the hair can get messed up. And maybe I nick myself when I'm shaving and there's nothing I can really do about that. Well, when you transition to the social media universe, things change quite dramatically. Our ability to curate the way we present ourselves goes on hyperdrive. You can air brush out the blemishes. You can make sure that it's the perfect
一直都在，不仅在社交媒体上，在现实世界中也是如此。所以我醒来。通常，如果我知道我要见其他人，我会刮胡子，梳头，穿上一件没有破洞和污渍的衬衫。我这样做是因为我想传达一种特定的印象。但是这种印象管理过程在现实世界中是有限制的，对吧？比如我可以梳头和刮胡子，但是，你知道的，头发可能会弄乱。也许我在刮胡子时划伤了自己，对此我真的无能为力。好吧，当你过渡到社交媒体世界时，事情发生了相当戏剧性的变化。我们策划自我展示方式的能力进入了超速状态。你可以用喷笔抹掉瑕疵。你可以确保它是完美的
snapshot, right? It's like the one photo out of the hundred you take in that really captures things best and you can post that. And so then the question is, well, what happens when you are logging in and not only seeing this this kind of hypercureated presentation of other people's lives, like not just a single snapshot, but when you're scrolling through a series of snapshots, right? So everyone is looking great. Everyone is having a great vacation. Everyone is talking about good things. There's basically lots of 50 years of psychology gives you an answer to that question, right? Like what happens when you bathe yourself and the positive experiences of others can lead you to feel bad about your own life because you are aware of the normalcy of your own life,
快照，对吧？就像你在拍摄的一百张照片中真正捕捉得最好的一张，然后你可以发布它。所以问题是，当你登录并且不仅看到这种高度策划的其他人生活展示时，不仅仅是单一快照，而是当你滚动浏览一系列快照时，会发生什么，对吧？所以每个人看起来都很好。每个人都在度过一个美好的假期。每个人都在谈论美好的事物。基本上，有50年的心理学研究为这个问题提供了一个答案，对吧？比如当你沉浸在他人的积极体验中时会发生什么，这可能会让你对自己的生活感觉不好，因为你意识到自己生活的正常性，
meaning you're not just having all positive experiences and so forth. And so that's what we and others have found. And the take home, I think, is that if one way to try to minimize this is to try to use these sites more actively to connect and share with other people, there's some evidence suggesting that is less harmful in terms of the emotional implications. And as we wrap up, I just want to focus on one more study you did that I think we'll have implications for this year, which is an election year here in the U.S. It's from a study you co-authored, in 2011 that examined how people fail to be reasonable over issues that have deeply personal implications, like an election. In that study you focused on the 2008 U.S. presidential election.
这意味着你并非只有积极的体验等等。这就是我们和其他人所发现的。我认为，核心启示是，试图最大程度减少这种情况的方法之一，是尝试更积极地使用这些网站来与他人联系和分享，有一些证据表明，就情感影响而言，这的害处较小。在结束之际，我只想关注你的另一项研究，我认为这对今年会有影响，今年在美国是选举年。这是由你于2011年合著的一项研究，该研究探讨了人们为何无法在对个人有深远影响的问题上保持理性，例如选举。在那项研究中，你重点关注了2008年美国总统大选。
Can you explain more about your findings and what, if anything, has changed in the past nine years? Yeah. So in that work, what we wanted to do is look at how, how distance in which we've talked about thus far, how its ability to step outside yourself and look at the situation more objectively, how that might influence something like wisdom, which we defined as, like, so wisdom is the ability to manage social dilemmas effectively. And two important qualities of wisdom, so what makes someone wise, it's recognizing the limits of one's own knowledge, this understanding that, look, as much as I may know about something, I can't possibly know it all. So intellectual humility is something that's often referred to. and then also something called dialecticism, right? Fancy word to basically convey the idea that the world is constantly in flux and things are likely to change.
你能多解释一下你的研究发现，以及在过去的九年中有什么变化（如果有的话）吗？好的。所以在那个工作中，我们想要做的是看看，我们迄今为止讨论过的距离，即跳出自我并更客观地看待情况的能力，它将如何影响诸如智慧之类的东西，我们将智慧定义为，智慧是有效管理社会困境的能力。智慧的两个重要品质，即是什么让一个人变得睿智，是认识到自己知识的局限性，这种理解是，你看，尽管我对某事可能了解很多，但我不可能什么都知道。因此，这通常被称为智识谦逊；然后还有一种叫做辩证思维的东西，对吧？这是一个华丽的词，基本上用来传达这样一个观点：世界总是在不断变化，事物很可能会发生变化。
And so what we wanted to do is see whether asking people to think about the election. And what was going to happen if the person who you didn't endorse won the election? Granted, things currently are, I think, much more emotionally charged than they were back in 2008. But the question was, like, does getting people to think about the upcoming consequences of election from a distance perspective lead them to be less extreme in their reaction? So might it lead people to say, well, you know what? It may not pan out the way I want, but I get that this happens every four years. And, you know, this candidate will come and maybe they'll go. or I don't know, maybe they will surprise me.
所以我们想看看，要求人们思考选举会怎么样。如果不支持你的人赢得选举，会发生什么？当然，我认为现在的情况比2008年时情绪化得多。但问题是，让人们从距离的角度思考选举即将到来的后果，是否会让他们在反应上没那么极端？所以这是否会让人说，好吧，你知道吗？事情可能不会按我想要的方向发展，但我明白这每四年就会发生一次。而且，你知道，这个候选人会来，也许他们会离开。或者我不知道，也许他们会给我一个惊喜。
So getting a little bit more humility emerging in your forecast as well. And that is in fact what we found. So the people who were capable of distancing when they thought about what was going to happen showed evidence of being more aware of the limits of their own knowledge and were more likely to indicate that the future was likely to change in ways that they couldn't predict. And do you think that would be effective, you know, this election year and subsequent election years? The ability to adopt that kind of mindset?
因此，在你的预测中也会涌现出更多的一点谦逊。事实也的确如此，这就是我们所发现的。因此，当思考将要发生的事情时能够保持心理距离的人表现出更清楚地意识到自身知识局限性的迹象，并且更有可能表明未来很可能会以他们无法预测的方式发生变化。你认为在今年以及随后的选举年中，这会有效吗？拥有这种心态的能力？
Yeah, well, I think it's a great question, you know, to see what happens there. As I said, like, I think the stakes now are, I think, higher in many ways. My intuition is that this is a much more emotionally charged climate that we are living through. So I think one question is, like, are people capable of distancing? because it may be more challenging to do so, the more immersed you are in the experience. I think people now are very immersed. But I do think that if you are capable of getting some space,
是的，好吧，我认为这是一个很好的问题，看看那里会发生什么。正如我所说，我认为现在赌注在很多方面都更高。我的直觉是，我们生活在一个情绪化得多的气候中。所以我认为一个问题是，人们能够保持距离吗？因为这可能更具挑战性，你越是沉浸在体验中。我认为人们现在非常沉浸其中。但我确实认为，如果你能够获得一些空间，
you do realize you're more likely to realize that as challenging as things may be, if they don't work out the way you want them to work out, we do get to do this again in four years, right? I mean, like, think about the ultimate distancing exercise here when it comes to a political climate. Like, we've been around for a while, our species on this planet. We've experienced changes in leaders and, you know, the borders of nations, and so to speak,
你会意识到，你更有可能意识到，尽管事情可能充满挑战，但如果它们没有按照你希望的方式发展，我们四年后确实还有机会再来一次，对吧？我的意思是，就像，想想政治气候下终极的心理距离练习。我们的物种在这个星球上已经存在了一段时间。我们经历过领导人的更迭，你知道，还有国家边界，等等，
and we've made it through, right? So we will likely do it again. This same idea, this same kind of perspective, broad and distancing was, I think, recently applied very effectively when talking about the coronavirus, the coronavirus that we're dealing with, right? Like most of the media is focused, is zooming us in on just how much deadlier this virus is than the seasonal flu. And this is causing a lot of panic among people. I think it's the evidence of this when you just look at the masks flying off the shelves at every drugstore and Costco across the nation. Well, one public health official recently said, this is not an existential threat.
我们挺过来了，对吧？所以我们很可能会再次做到这一点。同样的理念，这种同样的视角，宏观和心理距离，我认为最近在谈论冠状病毒时得到了非常有效的应用，我们正在应对的冠状病毒，对吧？就像大多数媒体所关注的、放大的只是这种病毒比季节性流感致命多少。这引起了人们的恐慌。我认为这有据可查，只要看看全国每个药妆店和Costco货架上被抢购一空的口罩就知道了。好吧，一位公共卫生官员最近表示，这不是一个生存威胁。
We have experienced pandemics like this before. Epidemics, pandemics, use whatever term is appropriate right now. And we've lived through it. And we will live through this again. And that, again, that's a perspective broadening tool that they invoked, that at least in terms of the reaction, the effect it had on me, it was quite powerful. And I suspect it would be on others, too, based on what I know about the science behind it. So earlier you mentioned you have resources for people to go for more information. Where should they go?
我们以前经历过这样的流行病。流行病，大流行病，现在用哪个词合适就用哪个词。我们已经经历过它了。我们将再次度过难关。这再次成为一种拓宽视角的工具，他们调用了这种工具，至少就反应而言，它对我的影响非常强大。根据我对其背后科学的了解，我怀疑它对其他人也会产生同样的影响。所以你刚才提到你有资源供人们获取更多信息。他们应该去哪里？
So they could check out my website for my lab, the University of Michigan Emotion Self-controlled Lab. And there are lots of articles and news coverage on some of the things we talked about there. And I also have a book coming out on this called Chatter, The Voice in Our Head, Why It Matters and How to Harness It Coming out next year that will integrate a lot of the things we discussed that they could check out. out too. Great. Well, thank you so much for joining us, Dr. Cross. This has been a really awesome conversation. I think we'll have people talking, whether it's inside their head or outside their head to other people. Yes. Thank you so much for having. It was a lot of fun. If you have any comments or ideas to share, send us an email to Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. That's speaking of psychology, all one word, dot org. And also please consider giving us a rating
因此，他们可以查看我实验室的网站，即密歇根大学情绪自我控制实验室。那里有很多关于我们讨论过的一些事情的文章和新闻报道。我还有一本关于这方面的书即将出版，书名叫《喋喋不休：我们头脑中的声音，为什么它重要以及如何驾驭它》（Chatter, The Voice in Our Head, Why It Matters and How to Harness It），将于明年出版，其中将整合我们讨论过的许多内容，他们也可以去看看。太好了。好吧，非常感谢你加入我们，克罗斯博士。这是一次非常棒的谈话。我认为这会让人们展开讨论，无论是在他们脑海里还是在脑海之外与其他人的讨论。是的。非常感谢邀请我。这非常有趣。如果您有任何评论或想法要与我们分享，请发送电子邮件至 Speaking of Psychology at APA.org。即 Speaking of Psychology，所有单词连在一起，点 org。另外，请考虑给我们评分
in iTunes. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on Apple, Stitcher, Spotify, or wherever you get your podcasts. You can also go to our website, speakingof psychology.org. I'm Caitlin Luna with the American Psychological Association. Thanks for listening. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在 iTunes 上。您可以在 Apple、Stitcher、Spotify 或任何您获取播客的地方找到《Speaking of Psychology》的往期节目。您也可以访问我们的网站 speakingof psychology.org。我是美国心理学协会的凯特琳·卢纳。感谢收听。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。